this line tells a story the story
changes depending on whether the line
climbs up plateaus or the line goes down
what did the lines created by Kovac
nineteen data tell us not only country
to country but state to state and even
within different counties
there's rapidly different spread
depending on what's going on in your
community so it's helpful to look at
different things together including
cases hospitalizations and deaths a lot
of these metrics vary based on who's
reporting it and they're reporting them
in slightly different ways the number of
confirmed cases is likely lower than the
number of actual cases because not
everyone has been tested and a lot of
the milder asymptomatic cases were
likely missed especially earlier on in
the pandemic states have different ways
of keeping track of how many people are
in the hospital being treated for Kovac
19 some states don't report this and the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention doesn't require it and then
some states also give you age and
underlying health condition data and
other demographics such as recent
ethnicity though that's not uniform
across everywhere so the hospitalization
data that you're gonna find depends a
lot on where you are seasoned counties
also have slightly different methods for
counting death but it's one of the more
solid data points that we have to
actually figure out how far and how
severely the disease spread but like the
number of confirmed cases the number of
Cova death is also likely higher
especially since we didn't test a lot of
people's work in the beginning of the
pandemic some states are going back and
Counting deaths presumed to be from
kovat 19 that may skew the trend
what you'll see is a spike in deaths in
some states that recently happened in
New Jersey when there was a spike but
actually they just went back and added a
lot of their presumed deaths to their
total death count there is a metric lag
between the data points confirmed cases
hospitalizations and deaths you'll
likely see keep this followed a week or
so by hospitalization and then death
usually lag behind those because usually
with this disease people are sick for
weeks before they die public health
authorities also track the positivity
rate that compares the number of tests
that come back positive with the total
number of kovat 19 tests are necessary
but if the positivity rate is low most
of the cases are likely being captured
and you're probably doing enough testing
to capture all of the cases but keeping
track of how the positivity rate is
changing now that there is wider spread
testing is important because if the
positivity rate is going up over time in
a specific area that likely means that
there are more cases being found and the
disease is spreading sometimes there are
spikes or adds or different patterns
like for instance cases that reporting
usually slows down on movies and so it's
important to look at averages whether or
not it's over five days or seven days to
sort of smooth out all of the slack and
look at the trends over time who's
looking at just one day or just the last
couple of dudes likely isn't going to
give you a clear picture
[Music]